if you want to change your life change
your outcomes it starts with you
changing your consistent morning routine
you have to figure out what the best
morning routine looks like for you and
that can come from trying on different
people's hats and their schedules but
you have to have something everybody has
something nobody just wakes up and then
hopes that amazing things happen not
people who are successful a lot of
people wake up like that though most
people wake up and hope something
happens to them hopes they win the
lottery hopes to get the promotion hope
some big customer calls them right we're
just living in a Land of I hope
something big happens to me but I don't
believe it's going to as opposed to
demanding Excellence from yourself every
day and it begins with your morning
routine so how can you do it I'm going
to give you a three-step process that I
think will help new motivation watch top
10 with believe Nation hey it's Nina
Carmichael we made those videos because
you're the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more you just need that Push by surround
yourself with the best so let's learn
from one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and his top 10 rules for
Success enjoy
step number one is figure out what makes
you soar so I said this is the most
important part of my morning routine
what makes you come alive and soar what
makes you feel like the work that you do
matters and you have to show up today so
for me I have to think of a message
every day I think about you guys every
day I I wake up I'm here in my Toronto
condo it's hard to imagine that 300
million people have seen my videos and
that the number doesn't make any sense
right and so it's easy just to wake up
and just continue to live my life me my
dogs my wife and my condo and and just
another okay day right
I have to remind myself that the work
that I do matters I think of a message
and then I share it and I take out my
phone and I post something to Instagram
typically right and that sets me up that
reminds me that what I do matters is
Meaningful I need to demand Excellence
for myself what is it for you maybe it's
creating a piece of content maybe it's
making a video maybe it's watching a
video maybe that maybe this is part of
your morning routine thank you and it
helps you soar right maybe it's doing a
good deed maybe it's meditation or
prayer or walking the dog or playing in
the in the sun like whatever it is what
makes you come alive you have felt it
before you have felt it before you've
had moments in your life where you were
bold confident Unstoppable powerful
where you felt like you could take on
the world right but you felt like your
crazy ideas were possible you felt that
before I know you have the problem is
the problem is it's not consistent
you're not consistently feeling that way
and so you need to reverse engineer
yourself before you worry about taking
on other people's routines and ideas
which are definitely helpful reverse
engineer yourself to figure out when in
your life did you feel the most bold
confident powerful alive and what led to
that happening what led to that
happening and then put that into your
morning routine demand it from yourself
every day
right so it could be reading it could be
watching video all the things I talked
about it doesn't matter you felt it
before reverse engineer what that thing
was and then put it into your morning
routine because if you woke up and you
did the thing that made you soar that
made you feel bold Unstoppable powerful
confident every single day holy cow get
ready for a massive change in what your
life looks like over the next year step
number two is ask the high performance
coach question so again I'm going
through all of this stuff with Brendan
I'm going through all this and my
favorite question
was the one I read
if I was a high performance coach this
is what you should ask every day I like
this if I was a high performance coach
looking at my life from a high level I
would tell myself to remember that
because it's so easy why I love this is
it's so easy to look at other people's
lives and say what needs to be fixed
right you can look at your spouse your
friends your team your parents your
siblings you know your high school mates
whatever you can look at other people
and say that needs to be fixed you got
to go off and do this right you you
become the high performance coach for
other people and what I love about this
is that you're looking at your own life
today as a high performance coach what
would you tell yourself
and then they have one at the end of the
day uh if I was my own high performance
coach I would tell myself this statement
about today so of all the things on here
it's a great format I like that the best
and so I would challenge you for the
next 30 days to ask yourself that simple
question if you were
a high performance coach looking at your
life from a high level you would tell
yourself to remember that what and then
step number three would be which three
people can you model their routine so
Brendan you know he's got his and I'm
I'm modeling this for at least 30 days
I've added you know John Assaraf a
friend of the channel been on a couple
times uh talks about writing down your
goals every day and then and then
touching them right so I'll write down
some goals and then I and then I write
them every day now and I'm touching them
right that's what he does great again
you got to see what's gonna work for you
maybe I do that for 30 days and stop
maybe maybe it's what I do for the rest
of my life I don't know you won't know
until you do it consistently enough so
pick three people who you like pick
three people who you respect who you
look up to say this is the kind of
person that I want to learn from and
then go investigate how they start their
day and then and then try on some of it
right you might love the Rock and he
works out for four hours a day you may
not be able to do that but you can work
out for an hour a day right because
maybe you're doing nothing every day so
it's a good starting point like just get
to the gym and start working out every
day right so pick 3 three people who you
love look up to respect admire and then
go research what are their morning
routines and how can you apply one thing
from each of them to see if it works for
you rule number two act on your ideas
chasing down your dream is scary chances
are nobody around you has done anything
close to what you want to do and they
don't understand you they think you're
crazy well you know what here's the news
flash you are crazy and you need to
embrace your crazy ideas right now all
your regret for the rest of your life
that you never took action so I'm a big
believer that you need to trust your
crazy ideas that when an idea comes to
you you have to go off and do it you
have to teach yourself that you are a
genius therefore you come up with genius
ideas and you need to birth them into
existence because it came to you
therefore it's good at least that's what
I tell myself and here's a quick example
I started a new channel last week
featuring IG lives of different
entrepreneurs one of the things that
frustrated me was that people Your
Heroes people that I love that I look up
to that you look up to are going live on
Instagram every day and the lives
disappear in 24 hours it's just a
function of Instagram is after 24 hours
the lives go away nobody can see them
anymore and I was frustrated for myself
and for you and that all this great
wisdom was being lost but I was also
frustrated for them for the for the
thought leaders for the experts For Your
Heroes that they're creating this
amazing content to help people and then
it just goes away and so I wanted to
help protect their legacy preserve their
wisdom and also have something for you
guys to be able to go back to again and
again and again access to thought
leaders and experts and heroes and so I
thought what if I just started a Channel
with their IG lives and I came up with
the idea on a Friday and then on Friday
we launched
Friday I started with my own live and we
had a live of one other person and I put
them up and we launched a channel set up
the email address set up the banners set
up the channel art set up the playlist
set up the rules and then started
training my team on how to do it and so
now we've got I don't know how many
videos a bunch of videos that have been
put up since we've launched a channel
and and that needs to be the speed at
which you start to move that you get
ideas and you don't sit on them how many
ideas have you had that you've been
sitting on for weeks for months for
years when I when I travel and I meet
different entrepreneurs it it saddens me
so much to see so many people
have had a dream for a decade plus and
still haven't done anything with it the
biggest problem is you're just not
acting on it and so you have to protect
your dream you have to you have to find
a spot that makes you come alive makes
you believe that you can do it but
protecting your dream doesn't mean doing
nothing on your dream right you have to
act even when the people around you
don't understand you think you're crazy
because again you are nuts it's amazing
and you have to embrace your crazy ideas
rule number three have shorter goals as
time has gone on I've become less and
less a fan of goal setting
and I love the idea of quarterly goals
over annual goals over decade-long goals
because the timeline is shorter and why
I'm less a fan of goal setting is
because
the more you're actually growing
the less likely you're actually able to
predict where you're going to be
so I really hate 10-year goals five-year
goals 10-year goals if you think about
where you were five years ago think
about who you were five years ago
five years ago look at the calendar five
years ago from today
in the past who are you
you think that person could predict
where you would be
10 years ago
10 years ago I just started my YouTube
channel
I had a couple videos up 10 years ago I
said I'd never want to write a book ten
years ago I wouldn't imagine that I'd
I'd be here I'd be here and making
videos for a YouTube channel with 300
million views in Puerto Rico because
Brendan Bouchard invited me to his
Mastermind group
speak on stage in front of all these
successful entrepreneurs I wouldn't have
predicted that like with with zero
accuracy
and same thing for you ten years ago you
had no idea that you'd be here not if
you're growing and this is the big
caveat not if you're growing like if you
can predict what
you receive where you're gonna be in 10
years
you can hit it but it's just way small
compared to what you could have done and
it means that you haven't grown in the
past decade
and so that's my main beef against bulls
and and
having shorter goals having numericals
can be great can be great like I want to
get 10 million subscribers on my main
YouTube channel that's a good goal
but if I set that as my 10-year goal and
that's the only thing I'm gonna do then
it's wrong because probably in three
years I should jump off and we'll do
something else right I've been fortunate
that I've been doing YouTube for 10
years I I still love it it's still
amazing but project is all your 10-year
plans you should jump off in year two
and go to something else because that
thing is actually better for you because
you've grown as a person
so at least that's great the advice that
instead of annual goals send it down to
quarterly goals because goals are still
helpful
they're so good to kind of track your
progress to know that this video did
better than that video that this
customer brought in more money than this
customer that are you doing enough
action to go and get the business that
you want
those are great
but as a macro thing that's leading your
decisions
I think the longer you stretch it out
the worse it actually is Rule Number
Four serve others so in terms of making
decisions you want to do things that
will serve other people serving others
is hardwired into us they did fmri scans
of the brain and when you help other
people it hits the same part of your
brain as food and sex more than
receiving more than getting gifts is
helping others serving others being of
use you want to wake up every day and
feel like the work you do matters that
you're having an impact we all want to
go off and have an impact you are built
to serve and so already in your decision
making does it serve somebody else does
it help other people in some way if it's
yes you're making progress in the book I
go through a three-step process who I
how so who your one word most important
core value what do you stand for who are
you you have one word that is more
important than all the others so I
believe is my most important core value
and so already the the decisions that I
make are through the lens of belief this
video is about believe I hope it's it's
my intention I may not always is execute
on it as best as I can but it's always
my intention and so if you understand
what your one word is then it allows you
to make your decision making process a
lot cleaner a lot simpler a lot easier
next is your why your purpose comes from
your pain your why comes from your pain
the thing that you want to help and
serve other people with the problem that
you want to solve is the same problem
that you went through the people who you
will love serving are the people who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled with your purpose comes
from your pain and so whatever was the
most painful moment in your life the
moment where you felt the lowest the
worst the the most worthless as a human
being your purpose for the rest of your
life is to help other people who
currently feel that way so think about
who you used to be who you were five
years ago whenever you were struggling
the most there's lots of people who
currently are like you used to be you
want to go serve them and then the how
becomes
how did you get through it how did you
get out of that problem you may not even
be fully out of the problem whatever you
struggled and suffered with you're not
done you're still growing you're still
learning you're still improving you're
still climbing that staircase you know
of knowledge and growth but every time
you take a step up on the staircase you
can reach back and pull somebody else up
one more step one more step The More You
Learn and Grow the more you can pull
people up with you and so however you
got out of the hole even though you're
not done you're better than you used to
be there's lots of people who currently
are who you used to be and so however
you got out becomes a recipe to teach
other people as well also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five find what makes
you happy
and then Having the courage and
confidence to step out onto that ledge
step out onto the ledge the ledge
and go live it and go be you because
it's hard because it's tough because
you're gonna get judged because we're
constantly comparing our version of
Happiness to somebody else I'm here in
Puerto Rico Brendan burchard invited me
down to speak to his Mastermind group
these people pay 30 to 50 000 a year to
be a part of it and I'm honored to be a
guest and
thing that I see consistently from all
the people who are here right imagine if
you're dropping 30 to 50K to be here how
much are you making
so that you want to come down right
everybody's doing the thing that makes
them come alive and that's a secret of
Entrepreneurship at least the ones who
are successful
that your version of happiness is going
to look different than somebody else's
you're a weird duck that's awesome go
live it Brendan came on stage and
started talking about his daily routine
button doesn't do anything
work related typically until about one
o'clock he wakes up he walks the beach
he meanders he plays with his cat he
does all of these things that get him in
the right mental framework and his first
call is one o'clock
so he said I want you guys to try
something
tomorrow go and walk the beach right
walk the beach
try that first thing in the morning he
moved the start time we're supposed to
start at nine start time to ten o'clock
because he wanted us to walk the beach
just as an experiment to see and I I did
it I went out and walked the beach and
it was good
but it's not the thing that brings me
happiness
right living in the
Tropical Paradise
it's not my thing
I like concrete
I like the concrete jungle I like being
steps away to everything I like insane
high speed internet you know
the things that make me happy are going
to be different than Britain and
burchard would be different than you
I was just about figuring out what the
heck is the thing that makes you happy
and then spending as much time as
possible doing that thing rule number
six build momentum if you want to be
thinking two to three years ahead and
still have success today then you need
to make sure that you have existing
momentum right now entrepreneurs we're
dreamers we love thinking about what we
can make two to three years down the
line it's an easy place for us to live
the biggest problem isn't thinking two
to three years ahead it's right now it's
at your lacking momentum right now in
your business you're a genius the only
thing you're missing is momentum so me
personally I've actually tried to go and
do the opposite of this advice most of
the time it's so easy to live two to
three years out that I want to now focus
on Mission what am I trying to
accomplish the big thing that's never
going to happen right I want to solve
the world's biggest problem I don't
think people believe in themselves
enough and that's why I wake up every
day trying to help solve but it will
never happen
and then what am I doing right now as
opposed to getting lost and what I can
do in two to three years because again I
think it's so easy just to live there
and then not bring it back to what am I
doing today to build momentum so I've
really tried to teach myself that as
soon as I get an idea for something to
start building momentum around it not to
get stuck in planning mode right it's
easy to get stuck in planning mode
here's where I want the plan to be in
two to three years you have to do Jeff
Bezos can think about where he wants to
be in two to three years because he has
an army of people doing work right now
building momentum on what's currently
happening if you're a solo entrepreneur
and you're just living in the future and
nothing's happening right now you're
never going to build that future so as
soon as you get an idea at least for me
I've been trying to teach myself I take
immediate action towards it it could be
something really big it could be
something like when I wanted to build a
house
I just decided I'm gonna build a house
and then a year later I had my house
built right from finding a dead property
that was empty to Excavating to building
a 5 000 square foot modern home
within a year I had my home built from
just having the concept and the idea
right teach yourself that as soon as you
get an idea you don't just sit you don't
just plan you don't just Tinker you get
out into the world and start doing rule
number seven alter your environment I'm
a big believer in altering your
environment I don't think that it has to
be physical to start so let me break
down a couple ideas for you that I think
will help one your physical surroundings
of where you are right now what's on
your wall what you watch the Youtube
videos that you consume hopefully my
channel the books you read all of that
starts the process of changing what gets
into your mindset more important than
the physical environment is this it's
what you're putting into here and so you
can start that from your home you can
start that from wherever you are and I
gain massive new belief in myself from
the video so my own channel if you're
consuming the content from guys like Dan
and going to Richard and Tony Robbins
and all these people every day in my
head it pulls me up it makes me think
bigger makes me feel like there's
something more and injects myself with
the belief and so you can do that right
now immediately look at your habits look
be routine look at the people you talk
to look at the the podcast you're
listening to in the videos you're
watching and is it part of a daily
practice it needs to be a daily practice
that you're putting that into here to
help you start playing a bigger game
rule number eight find amazing people
like me a key reason why you are not in
an amazing place right now is because
you do not have amazing people around
you think about it how many of the
people that you hang out with
consistently make you feel amazing force
you to grow and push you to be a better
version of yourself you can't do this
alone the people around you need to
change so you can change so I recently
came back from a mastermind group in
Puerto Rico with Brendan Bouchard and a
bunch of super successful people and one
of the things that I love the most was
how he works with his friends
and there's so many people who say don't
work with friends don't work with family
but he's built this group of people who
love working together some have joined
his team some are our business partners
and different Ventures where they're
genuine friends and they've been friends
for in some cases over a decade I love
that model I love working with people
that I that I know that I'm connected to
I love working with friends I don't see
it as business is one thing and personal
something else maybe that's just me I
would much rather work with somebody who
I get along with than just have a you
know business relationship and that in
particular made me think of my friend
Mark Drager and Mark's got a marketing
company called Phantom media we had a
podcast together called the supplement
pool podcast you want to go check it out
and I've known Mark for over a decade
and he sent me a message not too long
ago saying that what I need in a
marketing partner for my business isn't
what he can provide yet that he's still
a little bit away whether it's a year or
two years or whatever it is away from
being able to help me with what I need
both from a experience point of view a
resource point of view uh uh you know
team point of view that he wasn't ready
to help me and that he felt like he was
holding me back that if I had somebody
else then I would grow faster and
it never sat
right with me
until I went to Brendan's event and then
what came back was realizing I want to
grow with Mark I want to grow with my
friends I don't want to just be at the
top and then have a bunch of business
associates around me and then my friends
were like way down here right I wanna I
wanna build it together
there's value for me in building it
together Beyond just a business Roi and
I think ultimately long term it actually
leads to a Better Business Roi
and I love that I love that Brendan does
it and it provided a model for what is
possible for me to be able to go off and
create and build and so whether it's
Mark whether it's Alex from Toronto Dan
salsa whether it's Jeremy from the
YouTube coaching business that that we
started together
I like being able to work with people
who I can call friends
and I want to be able to do that more
and so whether you come on board and you
you you bring on your friends or family
uh definitely being around people who
push you who make you feel energized who
build you up who you could see for the
next 20 years being people that you want
to hang with I think is really really
really really really really really
really really really really really
really really important rule number nine
train the right skills you are spending
way too much time on things that you
hate doing that you never want to be
great at and it's hurting your business
I'm here in Puerto Rico I'm speaking at
an event with Brendan burchard his
Mastermind group and one of the things
I've learned from people who've
accomplished a lot have had big success
is that you are great at something right
you're you're the Michael Jordan of
something you have genius level Talent
at something
but you're not spending enough time
doing it
spending too much time on the things
that you hate
that you don't ever want to be great at
that you can respect and say hey this is
important for my business but it doesn't
mean that you should be the one doing it
so I spoke at this event and I'm talking
entrepreneurs and they're thought
leaders and they want to have their
YouTube channel they want to build up
their presence and brand name and
recognition and there's so many people
when they get started they spend 20
minutes recording a video
and in four hours editing it
to put the right graphics on to put the
right intro and extra music
now
if you are in the graphics business if
you are an editor then your stuff has to
look amazing
but if you're not then you're training
the wrong skill this is the thing you're
training the wrong skill there's things
in your business that you're spending so
much time on that you never want to get
great at you're training the wrong skill
you should not be doing it
discount it
doesn't mean you get rid of it
completely it doesn't mean that you
disrespect it completely but if you're
spending 20 minutes recording a video
and four hours editing in it you're
training the wrong skill you need to
switch it you need to spend four hours
recording it
four hours recording it and 20 minutes
editing it for zero minutes editing it I
don't care
because people who are watching your
videos if you're a thought leader
they're coming for this
they're coming for what's in your head
they're not coming for how great your
editing skills are now that doesn't mean
you disrespect the editing doesn't mean
you never hire an editor doesn't mean
you learn zero
but the thing that will get you to be
able to afford to hire the editor is
making awesome content that comes from
here because no amount of editing is
going to save it if your ideas suck it's
the thing that holds so many
entrepreneurs back from making videos
if you don't want to make videos you
don't want to be on YouTube awesome but
there's something in your own business
that you're taking that same equivalent
to so look at your calendar look at what
you're spending your time look at how
much time is actually being spent on
things that are moving the business
forward that you love that you could be
the greatest in the world potentially at
chances are that number is like five
percent
and you need to move it that needs to be
85 percent
that's when you start creating Magic
and it's not going to be perfect
releasing that video won't be perfect
you're going to look at it and say man
that really sucks I would love to have
better lighting I would love to have
better sound I would love to have better
editing I love that better gear great
work towards it but that can't be the
reason why you don't post and it can't
be the reason why you're spending all
this time doing work that you hate
you can only do so much by yourself
I love being an army of one right when
you get an idea you have to do something
about it you will it into existence and
if people don't want to help you then
you will it into existence be Nami of
one
but there's a lot of different ways to
win
you're going to win the hardest on the
thing that you're the best at
and so you start and so you start and so
you start
but you can't do everything not very
well
so you pick the thing this is the this
is the most important thing that will
help
leveraging your business to help to help
turn from just kind of making a little
bit of money kind of making a little bit
of momentum to have a massive momentum
to making way more
Leverage
figure out the thing
that when you do is fantastic
and everything else Almost Doesn't
Matter at rule number 10 the last one
before our very special bonus clip be
proud of your effort the greatest thing
that you can do for yourself is be proud
of your daily effort it's not about how
many likes or views or praise you get
that stuff doesn't actually matter it'll
hit you and make you feel great for a
second and then it fades the only thing
that matters is when you're all alone
looking at yourself back in the mirror
are you proud of the person that you are
looking at and for too many people it's
no and I want to change that in this
video so I recently came back from
Brendan burchard's Mastermind in Puerto
Rico with some super high level people
about 25 of us sat around the table
masterminded for three days and a lot of
people I've profiled here on this
channel and I normally hate these kinds
of events that are open that are loose
that require just now networking and
talking to people write it as a
structure or if you need help I love it
if it's and just spend the next hour and
a half mingling and talking to people I
hate it I even the thought of it right
now is making me cringe I hate it so
much
but when I got there Brendan challenged
me to say make sure you ask for help
make sure you don't just give give give
give but that you you leave here asking
for help and so that's always been a
challenge for me networking events plus
asking for help we're hitting like both
things that I'm historically have sucked
at and they struggle with and so I
decided I'm going to be proud of my
effort today I'm going to go off and do
it I'm I'm not going to go home I'm not
going to go back to my hotel room right
the hotel room was super close on that
two hour break 90 minute break three
hour break I could have gone back to my
hotel room and done some work I had lots
of logical reasons why I should go back
and do work everything is behind because
I'm not working
but really it'd be an excuse because I'm
afraid because I'm afraid of staying
there because I'm afraid of not being an
instruction environment because I'm
afraid of just talking to people because
I'm afraid to ask for help and so I
decided I'm gonna play full out I'm
gonna play for love I'm gonna maximize
this time I've got here I'm I'm taking
this time off of work because I need to
develop the relationships I need to get
the help that I need to get and I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask for it I'm gonna I'm
gonna be proud of my effort even if I
fail even if I suck even if it doesn't
work out I'm gonna be proud of my effort
and it wasn't the most uh amazing result
right it was awkward I was standing
around and trying to join people's
conversations it was super awkward and
cringe-worthy but I was proud that I did
it I was proud that I tried I can look
at myself in the mirror and said I did
that I tried my best pat on the back I'm
amazing
for other people who were there too
they're naturally extrovert they don't
understand what it is to be introvert to
be shy to joining on conversations to
not ask for help and how hard that can
be
uh so for them it was easy
to just start conversations and
introduce themselves for me it was
really difficult but self-worth
self-love self-pride comes from doing
difficult things that you don't think
you're capable of and so I was really
proud of my effort for doing it and if
you did the same thing it's something I
still try to do every day to be proud of
my effort in making this video I want to
be proud of my effort that I tried my
best to make the best possible video yet
you may not achieve it it may not happen
but if every day you woke up and you try
to do the thing to make yourself proud
right the effort you're going to create
amazing amazing amazing amazing things
where if you stay constrained by just
what you know and what you're capable of
and what you're good at you never grow
you just stay inside your comfort zone
forever and ultimately end up hating
your life
people aren't afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street corner you'll
record a video but you'll never release
it you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time also be your
own biggest fan that needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too an example was when I did
my tour
90 days 23 cities and I I did a paid
tour because I was afraid to do it and
this is supposed to be a free tourist it
was supposed to be coffee shop meetups
across the U.S low res super easy if one
person shows up great if nobody shows up
awesome if 100 people show up great
there's no risk right it's free you come
don't come whatever and my agent said
that's that's plain and small you got to
charge for the event and my first
reaction was oh my God I can't charge
for this event right like
choking up because I'm afraid because
I'm afraid that that if I start charging
for it then I need to I need to bring so
much more value
and because that was the reason then I
had to go off and do it if there was a
strategic reason why I should do a free
event then that that's fine my next tour
I'm looking at for 2020 is going to be
free is going to be ideally fingers
crossed I get my book deal it's going to
be at bookstores with my new book launch
so I want to do 20 something cities east
coast uh Texas Mexico with my book
launch and it's it's free to come
hopefully you buy a book but it's you
know not required but it's free to come
out because it's going to be supporting
the book launch that's a strategic
reason why I should be free I didn't
have a good reason why the first one
shouldn't be free what a tour this year
shouldn't be free and so I had to do it
I had to step into the fear you have to
step into the fear and do it because you
need to attack the thing that you're
afraid of especially when it's related
to other people right I'm not afraid of
failing I'm afraid of failing in front
of other people right I can suck all day
here in the office but I don't want to
suck in front of somebody else I don't
want to make people feel like whether
they're spending 50 bucks to come and
see me that was on tour or 2 000 bucks
to come see me at my thought Lucifer out
of me here I don't want people to feel
disappointed and because I feel that way
I need to step into it and I try to
teach myself attack it attack it attack
it if there's no good strategic reason
why then I have to do it because
otherwise I'm playing small and even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they they bring up
couples and they do a game show you're
afraid of what might happen on that game
do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur it makes you a thousand
times better as an entrepreneur because
that's the same fear that you face in
your business that fear of going on that
game show on the cruise ship that fear
of taking your phone and recording a
video in public on the street these
fears that seem like nothing they show
up everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle who cares if
you fail on the street corner making a
video great go do it if that if that is
scaring you right now do it teach
yourself you do it you have courage you
do scary things
but come on the other side you'll come
up with more strength and then you'll
start seeing things happen in your
business
you'll have more courage you'll have
more boldness you'll be more willing to
do things and then your business starts
taking off
you have to lose the fear of failing in
front of other people I'm going to give
you three ways on how to do it step
number one is embrace your bold ideas
I'm a big believer that when you've had
these moments of boldness maybe it's
happening right now maybe you're feeling
bold right now watching the video
amazing you have these moments of
boldness we have moments of boldness I
don't think people are bold all day long
right and if you are then you have
moments of even greater boldness hear
these moments these spikes these hits
right you go to an event I look at
people come to my thought Leadership
Academy they have these huge moments of
boldness right and then you fall back
down
and that's normal you're watching a
movie you get inspired you fall back
down you have a conversation you get
inspired you fall back down the
decisions that you make in the moments
of boldness I believe are the right ones
for you those are the decisions you have
to follow through on an Embrace and then
your head talks you down from them the
head brings you back down the plane
small
and so when you're feeling bold what
have you come up with I want to go do X
you have to do what do it you have to
start building momentum you have to
start committing to some other people
embrace the Bold ideas recognize that
those aren't the crazy ideas those crazy
ideas that come up with your affiliate
world are not crazy those are actually
the best ones for you you're just buried
under a pile of garbage of limited
beliefs on top of you those are the
things you have to go chase down and
when it gets hard when it gets difficult
when you want to quit remind yourself
this idea can be when I was feeling bold
I have to do it because I do both things
you teach yourself step number two is
expect to suck this is where it gets
super liberating expect to suck the
first time you do anything expect to
suck why do you expect to be great the
first time out what do you expect your
first video that you make to be great
it's not
it'll suck that's the best it should
suck right if you are if you are amazing
at making your first video then you
should have started making videos four
years ago I believe that you waited too
long your first at anything should be
terrible doesn't mean that you suck I
think you're amazing you're a genius
you're Michael Jordan you're the best of
all time it's something
but Michael Jordan didn't didn't dunk
his first ball right he didn't he didn't
shoot and it went in right away right
you suck at the beginning that's normal
learning any skill you suck at the
beginning and it's really hard because
you know what looks good if you want to
be a basketball player you know what a
good basketball player looks like if you
want to be a YouTuber you know what a
good YouTube video looks like but then
you can't do it yet your first one sucks
and that's where most people quit
because they expect to be good they're
worried about looking bad in front of
other people they're not good the first
time out and so then they never go back
to it and this is what happens when
people are growing up you fail all the
time it's normal it's okay you fall down
awesome you get back at me keep going
and then we stop trying as adults how
often do you try new things how often
are you willing to risk failure to risk
losing to risk looking like a fool
you don't want to so you're not trying
as much anymore and you ever find the
thing you could be Michael Jordan at you
never find it and you get stuck in some
life in some job that you hate forever
that's most people I don't want that to
be you you need to try more you need to
explore more you need to expect to suck
the first 18 times of doing something
you may suck amazing keep going the most
important thing is are you liking it do
you like the process successful people
love the process I love making videos I
like this process this fires me up I'm
just sitting here by myself in my office
talking to a camera I love it this is
great I love it for other people they
may hate it amazing don't do that go do
something else go go build little Teemo
toys right awesome whoever made this who
made this
designing California oh they didn't even
they didn't give them credit all right
design in California
right go make toys go do something go to
the thing that you love expect to suck
but if you love the process of it you
will get better
think about when you whatever you
learned in school most of it you've
forgot
but this thing that you remember the
stuff that you connected with that you
liked more so when you love something
you're going to just learn a lot faster
when you like something you're going to
get better a lot faster even if you suck
at the beginning you'll get better a lot
faster you have to find that thing and
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result what I want
you to do is go home and then sleep and
think am I proud of my effort am I proud
of what I did today am I proud of the
effort that I put in today I want to be
proud of my effort today in making
videos and I'm trying my best maybe it's
not good enough maybe today sucks
awesome but I'm trying
I'm proud of my effort I'm proud of the
attempt most people tie their software
to winning to the results to the money
to the gold medal to the to the whatever
right to the YouTube to the plaques back
there
you can't do that because if you tie
yourself forth to winning
you're only going to do things that you
know you're gonna win at
and therefore you play small for life
if you value winning above everything
else
you'll only do the things that you know
you're going to win at and so you play
small for life you stop trying new
things because you're gonna fail at the
beginning right expect to suck you don't
expect to suck you expect to be great
and then you're not and so you stop
doing that thing you'll only take on
small projects but you lovely more you
keep doing something much bigger
and so when you tie yourself forth to
the effort when you say I am proud of my
effort today
if you did that every day you're gonna
probably lose way more than most people
right you're going to be getting up and
losing almost every day and then you
have these big wins
but when you look back on this year of
losing you'll see holy cow how much have
I grown and you're actually winning way
more than most people way more than who
you used to be because you're proud of
your effort if you get up every day and
you're part of your effort
your life will change your business will
change like every day for the next year
do something that makes you proud of
your effort in your business in your
relationship proud of your effort you
tried your very best today
your life will be dramatically different
but it's because we're so focused on
winning you're so focused on the results
but then you you play small because you
don't want to risk losing you don't want
to risk failing your own risk looking
like an idiot
you have to if you want the life that
you're after
Michael Jordan missed more shots than
most people
you're going to fail at most things most
my videos suck and don't go anywhere
get up try again be proud of your effort
every single day think big
act small think big have a big goal Big
Dreams big desires big mission big big
Vision You're Gonna Change the World
think big let's go we love that as
entrepreneurs right let's think big and
change the world and act small
in that you got to do something
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
where what most people do is if you're
just thinking big and feel like you have
to act big from the start
then nothing ever ends up happening and
that big goal dies within you
we are afraid of taking the first step
we are afraid of building momentum we
are afraid of people seeing us
and nobody's seen us I just finished
this seven day challenge
and built to serve helping people become
thought leaders and people are afraid of
people watching their content and what
their what those people are going to say
and they're equally afraid of nobody
watching their content so you're afraid
of somebody seeing what you're doing and
judging you and you're also afraid of
people not seeing what you're doing and
you're creating an obscurity so you're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
at the exact same time is it any wonder
why you're not creating is there any
wonder why you're not making is there
any wonder why you're stuck and just
planning and strategizing and making
them the perfect thing happen before
something ever happens is it ever any
wonder why if you want to start a
YouTube channel you're still stuck on
what the opening sentence is going to be
and what microphone you're going to use
and what camera and what lighting and
what the background and how your hair is
going to look and your wardrobe is there
any wonder why you're still stuck on
that instead of just creating
because we're afraid we're afraid of
being seen and we're afraid of not being
seen at the same time and so we've
convinced ourselves why we can't do
something with with you know rational
logical reasons that we believe
are really you're just not making
content you're just not making progress
you're just not having the conversations
you need to have you're just not
building the business that you should be
building right whatever the thing is
it's just at the end of the day it's
just fear
and the thing that's missing is momentum
how I encourage people to get through it
is what I tell myself I expect to suck
at the beginning
whatever you do
when it's your first time expect to suck
right just expect to suck at the start
why do you think you're going to be
amazing the first time you go and create
something you're not it's gonna suck
it's it's not gonna be very good like
even objectively it's not going to be
very good probably
but that's okay doesn't mean you suck as
a person
I think it's amazing I think the fact
that you're willing to try is an
inspiration and so whenever you're first
getting started off when you have
expectations and then you don't meet
those expectations and this Gap this is
the gap that prevents you from taking
further action
how many times have you tried to do
something you got started you weren't
getting results like you thought you
would and you just quit right away how
many times have you recorded a video
watched it back were completely
embarrassed by yourself and then never
posted it and never launched your
channel there's been people who I've
done interviews with as their first
guest on their podcast or YouTube show
or Instagram whatever and then they
never post it
they never posted because they are too
embarrassed to even launch the show and
it was it was even a decent interview
but the insecurities and the Furious and
the doubts creep in and so they don't
they don't post it they don't do
anything about it where you just need to
expect a suck at the beginning
just expect a suck expected to be
terrible and that gives you the freedom
to go off and create because like
anything else whatever it is you want to
do you want to be a YouTube Creator you
want to be an entrepreneur you want to
be a coach an author a speaker whatever
it is that that your business is
it's all doable it's just a skill that
you need to learn there's there's a
bunch of skills that you need to pick up
and learn and like any other skill you
can learn it of course you can learn it
pick up any skill
but you don't have the skill right now
and so don't overly judge yourself for
not having the skill and not being good
enough as a human being just because you
don't have the skill set yet
right this isn't you're not good enough
as a human it's you're not good enough
at this specific skill set yet that when
you can figure that thing out and get
the trading education experience then
you can go and accomplish the goal of
course
but we overly judge ourselves and then
we don't build momentum
one of my movie makers
uh his name is Michael he's an amazing
human he
wanted to start making content want to
start making videos wanted to start
doing interviews and he was he was
afraid of asking people to be on the
show and him being the interview were he
was fine being an interviewee when
people were asking him questions but he
didn't want to be the interviewer and
was afraid to ask people questions and
so we had a discussion and we came up
with a concept where it was
um his show called his show is called
empowering conversations with a disabled
man so he's disabled he wants to help
reduce the stigma around people with
disabilities he wants to have open
conversations he wants to help people
who are disabled find Hope and
inspiration and power and he also wants
to
educate able-bodied people to how to how
to help support cherish their disabled
friends or the community and so we came
up with a concept of empowering
conversations with a disabled man and he
launched his first live interview where
he was having the conversation had a
guest come on and he was doing the
interview and it was the idea to action
that made all the difference because
he'd been thinking about doing a show
and thinking about making content and
you know being too afraid and being
stuck in his head like all of us do
myself included all of us do
and to his credit the thing that that
I did not do at his stage in this career
was he just went off and did it he just
okay you know what here's an idea I'm
gonna do something about it I'm gonna do
something about it I'm gonna get started
and he had his first one I asked him how
he did he said it was so much fun it was
so great it was so amazing and now he
scheduled the second one he's gonna keep
doing more it's a great win and that it
worked out now if he keeps going on this
show you know say he does 100 episodes
of the show he's gonna look back on his
first video and realize oh my gosh I was
so bad at the beginning right but look
at the journey look at the growth
same thing for you whatever you're
starting off doing and just expect to
suck at the beginning expect to suck
expect no results expect nobody to see
it expected to be terrible and tomorrow
you're going to keep going you can make
it a little bit better and a little bit
better and a little bit better and when
you look back on 10 days 20 days 50 days
100 days you'll come back and say holy
cow I'm really getting better why
because you developed a skill you were
you were still the same awesome human
now you're developing the skill set to
actually get better at the thing that
you want to do makes all the difference
the only thing you're missing is
momentum so just repeat yourself repeat
to yourself
the only thing I'm missing is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got the heart the care
the passion the desire to serve the
vision the just the soul to help you've
got all that you know you can help
oh you're missing is momentum just not
doing enough and that's not that's not a
beat down to say judge yourself and you
suck again as a person and you should be
doing more don't do that
but take the time that you spend
criticizing yourself and judging
yourself for not being good enough and
use that energy to then just go make
something and expect to suck so a couple
things that helped me that that that
gives me the permission to
to start so it's not a high bar it's a
it's there is no bar
there is the bar is solo that there is
no bar and that gives you permission to
just start and to create the momentum
you're looking for the other thing that
I find really helps me is
just trust that great ideas flow through
you
whether whether it's belief in self
whether it's belief in something higher
but just trust a good ideas flow through
you that if
an idea comes to you for something you
want to do trust it is a good idea trust
that that is the right idea for you that
you should do it that you should take
action on it and that it's going to
serve if you're in a positive mindset
right if you're if you're in a negative
mindset then then it's good to sleep on
your ideas right if you're in a jealous
mindset or hateful mindset or rageful
mindset then the ideas that come to you
are probably not the right ideas for you
but if you're in a powering empowering
inspiring positive optimistic mindset
then the ideas that come to you are the
right ones for you and just trust that
those are the right ideas and do
something on it and shortcut your brain
because as soon as your brain takes over
it's gonna be like oh okay but you don't
know how to do this and that and then
here's another problem and more
restrictions and you you know okay so
what happens default okay let's go
default to planning and researching and
we'll keep asking questions and we'll
keep him in high and then you know next
week I'll do something and then next
week comes and you haven't done it yet
right so when an idea comes to you you
find the smallest possible way to get
started on it today don't make it some
big giant thing that now you need a
million dollars in venture capital and a
huge team to accomplish
the only thing you're missing is
momentum right
so trust that great ideas flow through
you great ideas flow through you
you're here to do so much more
and take that kernel of an idea and do
something
whatever the smallest possible simplest
thing is to just build some kind of
momentum for it
to see how much did you love it how much
do you want to go back and do it
without having to pressure on it having
to be the perfect thing the next big
thing the only thing that matters
because that's what keeps you stuck
slow
knowing that you're capable of more but
too afraid to act
great ideas flow through you and the
only thing you're missing is momentum
let's go
your challenges don't only make you
stronger they allow you to serve better
I think the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
that I put in your way allow you to have
a a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humans are built to serve you
are built to serve when you can connect
the challenge that you're going through
as something that's then going to
inspire and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to just being about me getting
stronger I find a lot of times me
getting stronger is not enough it's not
enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not do I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believe in you not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash uh we're we're next so we're
probably gonna get some crazy noise we
have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time and look
we're next you guys can see this is this
car wash we're next depending on how
long that guy ahead of us takes you
might you might see it in this video I
dealt with a lot of those mindset issues
those lack of belief issues those
worthiness issues and I I battled them
and I've been through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did the path can
be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I've never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run
and I was doing Instagram live at the
times like a light run fast Jog and I
like my toe was hurting so much and I
just kept powering through I didn't
later realize I broke my toe but that's
not really anything major right you know
if somebody's going through something
physical and major it's like you broke
your toe come on it's not a big deal and
so I never felt like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I might have a concussion I'm
in more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was it
was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations the biggest hack to stop
caring about other people's opinions to
stop living other people's version of
your life and to start actually feeling
happy and proud of yourself the biggest
hack to doing that is to figure out what
you stand for to figure out your single
most important core value I believe that
everybody has a single most important
core value and when you figure that out
it gives you a lot more clarity a lot
more Direction a lot more confidence and
allows you to start to to do things that
you never thought were possible all of a
sudden that idea that you've gotta oh my
gosh I could do this thing but then
never take an action on it things start
to happen for you because you have that
Clarity of value so I wrote two books on
this your one word and built to serve
and we go through the process of
figuring out your one word or your who
who are you what do you stand for what
is that single most important core value
one of my favorite activities that I go
through I call it the five essential
questions but the most important one
there I find usually is asking people
who is your favorite teacher growing up
and why
so if you've understood the concept of
hey I need I need to have a core value I
need to know what I stand for I'm tired
of being on on quicksand I'm tired of
living other people's version of my life
okay great how do I figure it out do I
just pick one at random do I just read a
book like how do I actually figure out
what I stand for well
asking yourself that question who your
favorite teacher growing up was and why
I think it's critical think about it
you've had how many teachers in your
life think about your school elementary
school high school uh University if you
went to a college other teachers you've
had
you've had lots of teachers growing up
and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walk past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they were
because they had no impact
but there's always that one teacher that
stood out
there's one teacher that stood out for
you
why it wasn't because they taught you
grade 8 math
is because they made you feel different
as a human
they gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
Farr but I'm far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely used
French and on a day-to-day basis
what she taught me was to believe in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of uh
High School
and she would meet with me every week
the force before school started once a
week we'd sit down we'd chat we'd talk
about life we talk about school we talk
about where I was at we talked about
what's on my mind
and in those conversations she made me
feel like I could I could do more
that I that her belief in me created
more belief in myself
and in that last year I went from being
a b and c student to straight 90s
straight A Plus
I was still the same guy I still had the
same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had
it was just that belief in me that she
gave me that allowed me to go off and
start to perform more
so I think that's the most important
question you can ask
another one you can look at is what was
your favorite movie growing up and why
what's your favorite movie of all time
why there's so many movies that you've
watched most of them you don't remember
but there's one that that sticks out
that really stands out for you in some
in some way for some reason my favorite
movie is Seabiscuit it's about this
horse that is way too small it's about
this jockey that's way too big it's
about this owner that's bankrupt and
somehow they all find each other and
start winning a whole bunch of races
when when they they shouldn't be you
know and it's based off of a true story
and it ended up lifting a nation that
people love this Underdog Story and it's
a story of belief same thing
story of belief
we all at least for me I love the idea
of being that Seabiscuit or being the
jockey or being the owner
and helping not just each other believe
in themselves but also the nation for
the audience for the fans helping them
believe in themselves
and so if you started asking those
questions if you started thinking about
who are the people that make you come
alive that make you feel like you're a
better person and what are the resources
or what are the YouTube channels or
Instagram accounts or books or podcasts
or shows what are the things that have
made you come alive what are the things
that have made you feel
like you could do more
and then next to each one write down a
couple of words so your favorite teacher
growing up who was it and then why three
words to explain why your favorite movie
of all time
and then three words why and what you'll
find is as you do this exercise
you'll see some similar patterns you'll
see some words pop off the page you'll
see that same word come up a couple
times
that's your who
that's your single most important core
value
that's what you still need more of in
your life right now and that's what you
want to give to the world
the other great part about it is that
will be with you for life this isn't
something that we want to change this is
who you are this is your best
far I'm I'm the best when I believe in
myself and my biggest problem is still I
need to believe in myself more to get to
the next level
when you figure out your most important
core value you're who your one word
but what you need right now
my biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level
and it's what you want to give to the
people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big message
but some people like Nina who is just
here she doesn't have a big message but
she wants to help the closest people to
her
we all want to feel like what we do
matters we all want to feel like we're
having an impact on people whether the
closest people to us or to the world
but we're stuck and we're lost and we
need guidance and if you feel like you
have all these ideas but you don't know
how they all make sense
and you don't know that
you feel like it could be something but
you don't know how to get there
there's not enough momentum happening
is because you're not in touch with your
single most important core value
here's an example
if I'm struggling to do something I'm
struggling to get on stage to speak I'm
struggling to turn on the camera to make
a video for you I'm struggling to launch
my next project you know I get an idea
and then I say oh God I can't do that
what do I need
at the end of the day what I really need
like what's the thing that's going to
turn that idea into actual action
I do more belief
and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no when I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
believe more on yourself
because that's at the core of who I am
and when I can catch it then it gives me
the courage to go off and do it to
record the video to get on stage she
learns that project to say yes to say
yes to say yes I think of uh Alex who
helps me run Toronto dance also his who
was belong
he needs to belong more with himself and
he needs to spread more belong to the
world
and whenever he's not happy and whenever
he's not following through and whenever
he's not he in his goals and doing the
work is because he doesn't feel like he
belongs doesn't feel like he belongs to
himself and he doesn't feel like he's
spreading belong to the world if you are
stuck
are going too slow
if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you
thing that is missing
is you not following through on who you
say you want to be you're not matching
that potential
how you make it practical
to figure out your who
because every time you come back to that
you say I just need more of X I need
more hope I need more freedom I need
more belief I need more belong I need
more love I need more care for myself
and then to spread it to the world
and when you can feel that
when you can actually
it'll dramatically change how you show
up
all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a year
the chains you've given yourself wings
you've given yourself the permission to
actually go off and do the scary thing
that's inside you because now you know
who you are
figure out your one word figure out your
who
watch your life change the biggest fear
we have isn't failure you're not afraid
of failing the biggest fear we have is
of failing in front of other people
you're afraid of people's judgments the
reason why we stay stuck the reason why
you still are where you are is because
you're afraid of other people's opinions
you have
great ideas inside you you have great
ideas if you're watching this video
You're subscribed to this channel you
have great ideas you know you're capable
of more you know you want to serve you
know you want to help
and great ideas are flowing through you
and we shut them off
we shut them off because we find a
logical reason why we can't do it right
the logical reasons in our head are well
the timing's not right or I don't have
the gear right on the connections or uh
you know I'm in the wrong country or
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's that's listen it's based in
reality it's actually based in fact
because you wouldn't you're a smart
person you wouldn't believe a stupid
reason
so the reasons that we're listening to
are actually based on some kind of fact
but they're still an excuse and
underneath it underneath that reason why
you can't do something is because you're
afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underline that is not the fear of it not
working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you
you were so tied up into what other
people think about us that we'd rather
play small for life than actually go off
and accomplish and risk failing in front
of other people we're so afraid of that
that we never go off and
chase our dreams down and you're stuck
in this mental exercise of what you
could do
and then never actually doing anything
my biggest fear of disappointing people
you know it's that's still fear of
judgment it's still fear of I'm gonna
show up and speak in an event and it's
just not going to go well that that
people will
be unhappy with my speech and I put
a crazy amount of pressure on myself and
in my head I think people are here and
if I struggle then the whole thing is
ruined right I remember I was speaking
at printable shards event and uh it was
in Puerto Rico and people are paying
tons of money to be here you know it was
a 30 to 50 000 Mastermind and
everybody's got giant businesses right
these are multi-million dollar
businesses owners who are in the house
and it was a multiple Day event I think
it was a three-day event and I'm I'm
speaking for one of them not even a
whole day I'm speaking I have one I've
got an hour or something of time right
at that event
in my head it's if I suck on stage then
people will freak out and be unhappy and
say this was a total waste of an event
we're really I'm a really tiny nothing
part of this event right I mean people
are there to see Brendan burchard the
scene Dean graziosi to see the other
speakers there if any one speaker sucks
I mean if Brendan sucks that's a big
deal because he's speaking for 80 of the
time if I suck for one hour nobody's
really gonna care nobody's really gonna
be asking for a refund but
even though that's the the actual answer
it's not the it's not the thing that's
in my head and that's what we need to
fight that's what we need to fight
because I used to say no to
Opportunities because I was really deep
down just afraid that I would not be
able to deliver
I remember that I used to secretly hope
people would cancel on me
I would I would secretly hope that
interviews with cancer on me that
meetings would canceled on me
um
I remember I would book something out
like it's two months in advance right I
don't know if this has ever happened to
you this this makes sense or if it's
happened to you let me know in the
comments
I would book something out that was a
month in advance or two months in
advance and so yeah I'm like that's
exciting I'd happy to do that and then
on the day of I look at my calendar and
say oh that's coming up and I would
secretly hope I would check my email
remember I'd be checking my email hoping
that that person would cancel on me to
say oh I'm busy or I got sick or it's
not going to work out anymore and let's
reschedule and I remember I check in the
morning and I check two hours of four
and check an hour before and check half
an hour before and check 10 minutes
before and like if there was no email
then then I would go ahead and do it
so I'm losing insane amounts of
productivity right like how many times
am I checking my email before this thing
happens lose an insane productivity and
also not actually serving right not
actually living my mission my message
not not actually being proud of myself
for what I'm doing and it
it almost always worked out like I never
had an interview or a meeting or
something where I just massively
underperformed and actually sucked right
that that never really happened but I
was always afraid of it happening and so
I had to teach myself
this is this is what I want to do like
the only thing worse than me not doing
this is is me doing this and canceling
right or them me never doing an
interview I mean never doing a meeting
and just recognizing that it was just
fear talking and again the fears of me
disappointing people and feeling in
front of somebody else
I'm sitting here filming in in the car
Nina just came back we love you Nina
Nina's uh doing some grocery shopping
and I'm filming here you know in the car
we got the dogs here in the back seat
timo's chilling and this used to make me
afraid you know that look there's a guy
who just pulled up next to me
she's not watching but in my head you'd
be like this guy's watching
you can't be afraid of filming in a
parking lot be afraid of filming uh
walking down the street I'd be afraid of
filming with my sister in the room you
know I used to be afraid of all of that
so what is that
it's just fear of other people's
opinions why am I afraid of this guy
why I'm afraid of that guy I don't know
that guy
right
why am I afraid of him and his opinion
first off he doesn't even care right
he's not even looking at me he doesn't
even care maybe he never even noticed
that I was filming period right so we
think people care they don't care
on the off chance that he actually cares
uh maybe he is judging me and thinks I'm
crazy holding this camera up with with
the tripod in my hand maybe he thinks
I'm crazy great uh if somebody's leading
with that then then they hate their own
life like if somebody's leading with
just negative judgment he's got his own
issues to deal with that have nothing to
do with me or maybe he's inspired maybe
maybe this guy goes look he pulled out
his phone maybe he's making his own
YouTube video maybe he's inspired maybe
that guy is now going to be the next
YouTube sensation let's go
so we assume that everybody's gonna
watch us everybody's only looking at us
and
and we're gonna disappoint and be giant
failure and everybody's gonna laugh for
me to kill us right like that's the
thought that's that's in our head where
the reality is most people don't care
[Music]
most people right like 90 of people
don't even care
five percent of people might judge you
and they're in a really negative spot
themselves and the other five percent
maybe they're inspired by you and they
see that and they go and do something
with their life
but you playing small and listen to that
fear instead of actually taking some
kind of action will always lead to a
negative spot like you know that you
could do more you want to do more you
want to serve on a bigger scale but
listening to that fear
instead is keeping you stuck this is one
of the biggest problems for
entrepreneurs is that you you have all
these great ideas that are flowing
through you right you've got you've got
an endless list of ideas how big is your
list of things that you could do that
you get excited by when you look at them
and then how many are you actually doing
well not very many you're missing the
momentum because at the end of the day
you could write down a list of all these
reasons why it can't work out and and
when the timing is going to be just
right and perfect right I'll start this
on January 1st or start this next month
or next week or Monday or my birthday or
some artificial day you come up with
some reason of when you should be
starting this thing right but if you
actually examined it if you actually
took a little step back and looked at
your goals that you haven't hit that you
haven't started that just remain an idea
and you've never taken momentum on if
you actually took five minutes to step
back from it create a little distance
and look at them
and look at your list of reasons why you
haven't started really it's just fear
and when you can catch that
that's when you make a life-changing
decision
because as long as you are
not chasing down the things that you
want to do because you're afraid of
somebody else's Judgment of you as long
as that is the thing that rules you you
will never win you will never accomplish
anything great and you'll you'll live
life with regret so even now my my
biggest fear is still disappointing
people
and the ongoing challenge is to catch it
and when you can catch it and when you
can know BS
catch it to say I'm just throwing up a
bunch of excuses but really I'm just
afraid when you can catch it
then
some of the courage to go do the
difficult thing summon the courage to
say I'm gonna I'm gonna take this fear
head on
because as long as that fear runs your
life
you stay stuck
and every time you catch the fear and
you do it because of not just feel the
fear and do it anyway Feel the fear and
do it because of
you start to teach yourself to be a
little stronger a little more courageous
and you move a little bit closer to
becoming the person that you are capable
of being I'm going to substitute mission
for purpose your purpose is what you are
here for your purposes what do you wake
up excited to do your purposes what's
the impact that you want to have on the
world what do you want to be known for
what do you want to create
your purpose is the thing that keeps you
going when when you want to quit when
you want to give up when you feel like
it's not happening fast enough when your
goals aren't enough to keep you going
what is the thing that keeps you going
it's your purpose to feel like what you
are doing today matters is Meaningful is
it going to have an impact and
people have asked me somebody asked me
yesterday to do an IG live and somebody
asked me how do you
how do you keep going you're one of the
most consistent people I've ever seen in
my life
uh how do you keep going how do you keep
making videos well I feel like it
matters I'm living my purpose I don't
think what I'm doing is that unique
that's special I think everybody can do
it
it's it's within reach for everybody to
do it the problem is most people are
just chasing opportunity
and just trying to make a quick buck and
making money is very important it is
very important it's just not number one
number one is your purpose
if you woke up and felt like today
mattered that was gonna mean something
to somebody you're gonna show up in a
totally different way you're going to
show up with more energy it's going to
be easier to say yes
I was making videos for years with
getting
almost no views zero comments why
because I felt like what I was doing
mattered that if a hundred people saw my
video that's 100 people that saw my
video where if you're just chasing the
end goal if you're just chasing oh I
need to have a million subscribers so I
need to have X in my bank account
you stop you will quit because it gets
too hard
where if you actually felt like I'm
gonna show up today and I'm gonna do
something that matters and it's going to
change at least one person's life there
are some days when you feel like you can
change the world right there are some
days when you feel like I can do
anything I could change the world I'm
going to X right there are some days
when you actually feel that and it's
amazing and there are some days where
that feels too big and too scary and
your purpose feels too overwhelming and
and it should be it should be
aspirational it should be beyond your
reach it should not be something that
just gets solved in your lifetime it's
something that you want to swim forever
to climb forever to keep chasing down so
there are some days where it feels too
big and on those days don't stress about
it being too big worry about hey I'm
just gonna help one person for me when
I'm stressing out about making content
making videos
speaking on stage whatever else I'm
doing some days like I'm gonna change
the world today and other days is
I hope I can reach a few people with a
video
this is a Tuesday for me I record videos
on Tuesday every Tuesday I make content
into my calendar and it's always the
most
stressful day for me
in my week because I always want to make
the best that I can I want I want
today's video to be the best that I can
with what I've got
because I want to have an impact I want
I want hopefully this video and the way
that I say it and just hope that this is
the one that finally resonates with at
least one person The Hope isn't I need
this video to go get a million views or
I'm a failure the hope is
that for you maybe for you maybe you're
the one today
that the way that I say it
hits you in the right spot that pushes
you towards some kind of action to take
that thing that's been sitting inside
your heart that you've been sitting on
for a long time that you know you want
to do and get the permission get the
courage to actually go off and do the
thing
that's what purpose does for you
purpose demands that you grow into a
better version of yourself because you
won't do it just for yourself
if your goals are just purely selfish if
it's just to have money in your bank
account or buy a certain car or whatever
the goals just for yourself will not
sustain you through the long stretches
of bad times that it takes to go off and
actually build something meaningful the
thing that sustains you is feeling like
this is of Greater
service to other people than just me
Okay so
everybody has a purpose the purpose is
the thing that gets you going the
purpose is the thing that keeps you
motivated the person the purpose is the
thing that makes you want to do
something today how do you find it Well
finding it doesn't have to be a
difficult process I wrote about it in
built to serve I believe humans are
built to serve and finding your purpose
comes from your I call it your why and
your why comes in your pain your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose
it's not something that changes next
year or the year after or the year after
it's not it's not what's my purpose for
this year
that's a decent enough conversation even
figuring that out if you wanted to go
down that path what's my purpose for the
year it's already more self-awareness
than what 99 of the world has but that's
still not your life's purpose your
purpose is the thing that at 120 years
old you're still obsessed about my
purpose isn't to grow my YouTube channel
I don't know if I'll be doing YouTube at
120 years old that's too far away for me
to think about my purpose is to try to
solve the world's biggest problem which
is that people don't believe in
themselves enough and when I'm 120 years
old that will still be there and I will
still be doing whatever the the modern
technology is right if it's YouTube
amazing if it's VR something totally
different I'll be doing that because I
want to solve that problem
that's what I wake up everybody trying
to do why well because the purpose comes
from my pain because what I struggled
the most with
me oh Nina brought some coffee we love
you Nina
look at the steam look at the steam I
bought this guy coffee and you bought
the homeless guy coffee he said it's his
birthday it's his birthday look at Nina
so special
spreading her purpose love it my purpose
came from my pain I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur
I felt the lowest
as a human I felt worthless I quit on my
business partner I thought it was never
going to work out I I just felt
incredible pain I felt lonely isolated
worthless
and I did quit on my business partner
and then luckily I came back the next
day and just decided I can't quit on
this yet and I'm still making all of
this content all of my material how many
years later let's see that was that was
when I was 19 20. I'm 41 now so 20 plus
years later still helping still making
content still going and it's going to be
another 80 years of doing this because
there are so many people millions of
people who are 19 year old Evan right
now struggling with the same thing
whatever you struggled with
think about in your life that the
deepest
most traumatic experience where you felt
worthless as a human being the most
painful emotionally moment that you had
to go through
and you barely made it you know you
didn't you didn't Triumph your way
through it you struggled but you made it
and now you're here and you're still not
where you want to be but you're way
further ahead than you used to be right
you right now could go back to you from
10 years ago five years ago seven years
ago and give some great advice
that's your purpose
to know that there are millions of
people right now who are currently the
person you used to be and they may not
make it through
they may not make it through like you
did you had the strength you had the
courage you had the strategies you found
the way and you made it through and they
may not and they need you they need your
voice they need your hope they need your
inspiration they need your message they
need you in a way that they won't listen
to me they won't listen to Tom bilyu or
Tony Robbins they won't listen because
they don't connect to us but they will
connect to you because you are like them
so it doesn't have to take you years to
figure out your purpose you don't have
to go to a retreat you don't have to go
meditate on a mountain you don't have to
hire a fancy business coach you don't
you have to you don't have to do any of
that you already know it
you go back to the most painful moment
in your life
where you felt worthless as a human
being
and then just deeply connect to that and
feel and know that there are many people
out there right now who are that right
now
and they have no hope and no guidance
and no leadership and no wisdom and they
feel stuck and they then they feel alone
they feel afraid they feel ashamed
they're not reaching out they're not
asking for help and they're going and
they're searching they're searching
they're going to YouTube they're going
to YouTube they're going to YouTube
they're going to YouTube how many times
I say that they're going to Google
they're going to Twitter they're going
to Facebook they're they're searching
they're searching for help for answers
you could be the one that shows up
and if you actually felt that
[Music]
that on some days you could change the
world and on some days
you change one person's life if you
actually felt that
you'll show up completely differently
finding your purpose and living it is
the thing that gives you the motivation
the strength the confidence
to show up one more day and keep going
[Music]
this far new video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there the single greatest thing that you
can do to improve the quality of your
life is to take responsibility for it no
more blaming your parents or the country
or the government or your family or your
community